this second part of the evening
confrontation and cooperation in the
European neighborhood so the structure
is at first we're going to do some big
conceptual questions about the liberal
order and then the questions regarding
the neighborhood in fact there's a
overlap but I think you should feel free
the course of the discussion to continue
that but let me begin by introducing our
panelists first of all Michael a who
this year is at the transatlantic
Academy working on their project on
religion and politics he's a senior
fellow at the transatlantic Academy din
and he's been the senior adviser to the
German Marshall Fund since 2011 dr.
Leigh was director general of the
largement at the European Commission and
council of ministers from 2006 to 2011
sauce can't imagine somebody with more
experience in the questions of the
European neighborhood and was indeed a
theorist if you want a practitioner of
that policy the chief european union
negotiator with candidate countries I
know he has a lot of thoughts about that
experience and I'd like to introduce
Christina Lynn who's at the center for
transatlantic relations at Johns Hopkins
Christina Lynn is a fellow at the Center
for Trent was is a Phillips are at the
center for transatlantic relations at
the School of Advanced International
Studies at Johns sighs at Johns Hopkins
as well as 2013-2014 senior fellow at
the German Marshall Fund transatlantic
Academy when she focused on China's
increasing footprint in the
Mediterranean Basin this I think that's
probably what captured my eyes as I have
indeed visited containership port of
Naples and it is a marvelous structure
and it belongs to the Chinese with some
Swiss but mainly mainly Chinese so
Christine has also worked on ways at
China NATO and US allies can cooperate
to resolve regional security issues
Catdaddy napisze coma is that from
Cornell University and thinking we're
very much for coming down a visiting
scholar at the Center for International
Studies there she's also associate
professor of political science at
eCampus University in an open university
in Italy I'd like to learn more about
that her research focuses on issues of
democratization and the role of civil
society and political transformations as
well as a democracy promotion then I'd
like to introduce our two commentators
from Colombia because the idea was that
we would have commentators mix it all up
bring all of you in Cynthia Roberts who
is an associate professor of political
science at Hunter but we are also very
very happy to have you here as adjunct
associate professor dealing with all
kinds of important security issues she's
the author a book on Russia and the
European Union the the special
relationship the limits and sources of
that she's a specialist on contemporary
and historical aspects of European
security some of you might know her
because she's developed a capstone on
NATO which something we wanted keep her
teaching and Jack Snyder colleague in
the political science department the
belfer professor of international
relations and he's also assault man
institute for in peace studies at
Columbia and his research focuses on
international relations theory but he
has also a recent book which includes
elected to fight why emerging
democracies go to war which is good
co-authored with edward mansfield so
let's begin up to 10 minutes each and
then some comments and then we will open
up again to discussion
well thank you very much indeed for
inviting us to this very interesting
session and for your words of welcome
i'm going to try in ten minutes which is
a tall order to share with you some
thoughts about europe's neighbourhood
policy after all it was to some extent
the failure of this policy that led to
the developments that we've seen
subsequently in ukraine and in some of
the neighboring countries and where do
we go from here it was the refusal of
President Yanukovych to sign the new
association agreement with the European
Union that was the proximate cause for
the demonstrations in the Maidan from
for his ouster and old subsequent events
so I think it's very interesting to look
at this against the background of how
this policy developed and what the
aspirations were behind it and why they
did not succeed and where perhaps we go
from here in 2003 the European Union was
about to expand from 17 to eventually 27
and then 28 member states and on the eve
of this enlargement the Member States
thought it would be a good thing to send
a message to the countries that were not
involved in this process that
enlargement was not turned against them
that the relations that had previously
existed for example between the new
member states in Eastern Europe Poland
Hungary Slovakia who bordered on Ukraine
would not come to a crashing halt that
Europe would not become a fortress there
was a second set of motivations for a
new policy and that was after the
accession of Poland the Czech Republic
Hungary and so on this is often
forgotten there was considerable concern
in some member states that the next
country to apply for membership might be
Ukraine so the origins in fact of this
association agreement were not so much
the EU trying to draw Ukraine into
membership but rather to create
an alternative framework for refer
relations with Ukraine something perhaps
that we didn't really get across in
subsequent years the goal of this policy
has stated at the time was to create a
ring of well governed states around the
European Union in the Economist two
weeks ago the new shall men commentator
Tom Nuttall said instead of a ring of
well governed states we have a ring of
fire so what happened the vision that
European Union put forward in 2003 2004
with what started as the wider Europe
policy and then became the European
neighbourhood policy was basically to
offer countries to the east Ukraine
Moldova Belarus if it fulfilled some
basic democratic conditions that of
course it has not later on the countries
of the southern Caucasus and then it is
insistence about southern member states
particularly Spain the countries around
the Mediterranean rim a new framework
for our relations the idea in a nutshell
was that we would ask these countries to
commit themselves to a series of
political and economic reforms rather
similar to those that we had demanded
from the new member states in exchange
for which the European Union would open
up some of its policies the single
market it would provide additional
financial assistance it would facilitate
mobility in a kind of step by step move
the european union negotiators including
myself at the time went round all the
countries concerned and negotiated
action plans in which they signed up to
very ambitious reforms this was still
with the ASEAN regime of course in
Eastern Europe there had been the Orange
Revolution but around the Mediterranean
we were dealing still with the Ben Ali's
and the Mubarak's and so on but
nonetheless they signed up too ambitious
reforms and we promised them all kinds
of benefits in return ten years later we
can see that these ambitions some
to benefit from the enlargement
experience by sharing the same
methodology with the next group of
states who inevitably in our view at the
time little by little would wish to draw
closer to the European Union failed and
I think it failed for a number of
reasons one of the reasons was that we
had no vision of where this policy was
headed what was the end state were we
thinking of something like the European
Economic Area it wasn't quite clear was
this meant to be an antechamber to
membership not really but couldn't be
excluded for some European countries so
there was uncertainty as to where this
was leading but it was pretty clear that
it was not leading to membership so the
main incentive that the EU had to offer
to the countries in central Eastern
Europe for far-reaching reforms was
lacking another problem from the very
beginning was the split between the
European institutions on the one side
and the Member States on the other in a
way the Member States through this
policy had delegated to the EU
institutions the kind of values policy
the export of our legal structures of
our norms of our values while they
pretty much got on with business as
usual basing their policy on traditional
state interest that's why governments
are elected they did their job in a way
in which security trade and access to
energy was uppermost in their mind a
classic case which Illustrated to me
this dual approach which is one of the
reasons why the policy failed to work
was just a year or so ago when a former
colleague of mine from the Commission
now a Greek minister was in Baku
lobbying the government in Azerbaijan in
favor of the trans adriatic pipeline
rather than the EU project of Nabucco
west and he was engaging with his
government which in freedom houses most
recent report was described perhaps with
some exaggeration as one of the most
repressive regimes in the world and the
European Commissioner concerned Stefan
at that moment got up while my friend on
behalf of the Greek government was in
Baku attacked the government for putting
two opposition leaders in prison the
same day so the attitude the Member
State you know why are you screwing up
our bilateral relations whereas in fact
they had delegated to the EU the task of
exporting our values and trying to get
these countries to commit themselves to
far-reaching reforms another reason why
this policy didn't really achieve its
goals was the lack of clarity in
communicating to the beneficiaries and
also to others some of the fundamental
features of this policy and in the case
of Ukraine this failure of communication
I think was one of the key factors that
led to the disastrous series of events
that we've seen subsequently in 2008
after the Bucharest NATO summit when it
became clear after Russian objections
that Georgia and Ukraine were not going
to join the European Union Poland and
Sweden put forward the plan for this
Eastern Partnership which was the sort
of local module of the neighbourhood
policy with as its core a very
far-reaching deep and comprehensive free
trade agreement and the EU then spent
four years negotiating this agreement
now talking about clarity and
communication this was a free trade
agreement but with a very important
element of regulatory convergence
disagreement was entirely compatible
with the existing agreement between
Ukraine and the CIS the the free trade
agreement it would not have been
compatible with Ukraine joining the
customs union but this didn't get across
and nor did it get across that the EU on
far from seeking the membership of
Ukraine was putting forward an
alternative vision to this so there I
think there were extremely mixed
messages another reason for the failure
of this policy particularly in the
Mediterranean region was taking
month by on CM regime leaders at face
value and assuming that they really did
intend to implement these reforms in a
new version of the old Soviet joke it
looked as if these countries were
pretending to reform and we were
pretending to take them into the single
market and extend many of these benefits
so I think for a myriad of reasons
applying the enlargement methodology in
the absence of an offer of membership
without clarity as to the end goals and
with the Member States entertaining one
type of discourse and the EU
institutions another are among the
factors why this policy did not produce
a ring of well governed states but
rather a ring of fire another major
deficiency was the absence of strategic
vision there was no understanding of how
this policy would be perceived in Russia
and there was no dialogue with Russia
concerning the policy there was an
atmosphere of triumphalism after the
enlargement in 2004 it was an amazing
achievement the reunification of the
European continent to a considerable
extent under the umbrella of NATO and
the EU and we were on a kind of high
even later I think when the Arab
uprisings began we thought this confirms
our vision the Berlin Wall has fallen
one more time we've done this before in
Central Europe we'll do it again in
North Africa and the Levant we know how
it works we can support transition and
all this under the umbrella of the
neighbourhood policy but I think from
the purposes of today's discussion and
thinking about some of the main
challenges to our security the Russia
angle is perhaps predominant it's also
the next subject that the transatlantic
academy will be look at next year in its
program and after two thousand eight and
the bucharest summit the easily leaders
simply assumed that it was okay with
Moscow to see the EU engaging very
deeply with CIS countries NATO was not
okay but
the EU was okay and the Russians
contributed to this they did not
initially voice any objections and it
was only when the agreements were very
advanced and almost ready for signature
that it became clear that this was
perceived as the EU really treading on
the toes of Russia in its own
neighborhood and in countries that it
perceived as part of its sphere of
influence and by then of course the cat
was out of the bag it was rather too
late and this then led to the series of
events that we are now familiar with
ending up with these very severe
sanctions which mean that close dialogue
between the EU or the US for that matter
and Russia is now precluded at least for
the next year two years three years
before the dust has settled and
untempered have calmed and yet of course
we do need to engage with Russia on so
many issues whether Iran where the
process still continues Syria or other
cases where being in this hostile
relationship with Russia clearly does
not serve our our purpose so the new EU
High Representative for foreign and
security policy who will take office
next month in November if all goes well
with the hearings in the European
Parliament will have this neighbourhood
policy at the top of her agenda because
if the EU clay can claim to have any
sort of foreign policy if it can claim
to exercise influence in the political
world commensurate with its economic
weight this is first and foremost in its
own neighborhood and therefore I think a
radical review a new strategic approach
to the neighborhood is really top of the
new foreign policy Chiefs agenda I have
my own ideas as to where this policy
should go we don't have the time to go
into them in much detail but in a word I
think we need a meeting place with the
very pragmatic realistic approach of the
member states and the hitherto
idealistic approach
of the EU institutions which was in fact
not in line with the discourse
maintained by the Member States I think
that energy and security and trade need
to be at the heart of our policy not
giving up on support for democratic
forces where they exist and where the
demand is there in the countries
themselves as for example in Tunisia but
setting aside the idea that we can
impose in some sense respect for human
rights for democracy for the rule of law
from outside we can respond to civil
society forces to governments requesting
such support but we can't impose it from
outside and this is a mod of step
towards a greater degree of modesty
about our own influence in countries
beyond our own frontiers and to finish
we also need a much more highly
differentiated policy there's no use
having a common framework for countries
as diverse as Tunisia Morocco Algeria
Israel Syria which is covered by this
policy Jordan as well as Ukraine Armenia
Azerbaijan and so on and a final thought
is whether the concept of neighborhood
in other words directly contiguous
countries is really a policy relevant
framework when you look at the situation
today and the threats to security that
the EU and the Western general are
facing in the Levant for example Syria
and Iraq are now viewed as in many
respects posing a similar challenge for
all the obvious reasons Syria's part of
the EU neighbourhood policy Iraq is not
so did we choose the right geographical
framework for this policy there are many
other questions but I think this is an
item top of our agenda and I'm sure
there will be a great focus on this in
the hearings before the European
Parliament this week and next and in the
months and years
Thank
well good evening everyone first of all
I like to think the lingual European
Institute for hosting us for this event
I'm going to talk a bit about engage in
China in governance of security issues
and this is based on my chapter in the
report on the role of partnerships to
strengthen the West has a live as an
anchor to engage emerging powers China's
rise and its role in global governance
has been a subject of a great deal of
debate in the past decade whether dive
in the economic realm or security realm
in the global Commons but there seems to
be more diversions on economic
governance given China's penchant for
state capitalism or supporting
alternative blocks such as bricks or SEO
to bypass international institutions of
WTO IMF and so on and so my chapter
focuses on the security room where I
think there's more convergence of
interests I focus specifically on
engaging China on emerging
non-traditional security challenges such
as energy and maritime security
counterterrorism and arresting WMT
proliferation my bridge actually cover
some of that non-traditional security
challenges in her presentation because I
think that this where the west and
trying to have a lot of common ground to
forge a normative consensus and despite
some debates on Europe jointly pivoting
with the us to engage China in Asia I
focus on the transatlantic community
engage in China much closer to home in
Europe's own neighborhood in the
Mediterranean so let me first discuss
why US and Europe should engage China on
these new security challenges in the
Mediterranean and then I'll expand on
what a Chinese interests in this region
and provide some examples of how we can
engage in cooperative security which I
not to help shape a new security
architecture in the Arab Spring
aftermath so why should we engage China
in the Mediterranean first and not in
Asia there was the EU and US summit in
20 in November 2011 that transatlantic
partners initially discuss ideas of a
joint pivot to Asia and actually NATO is
debating an age of pivot as well and
upgrading ties with Asian global
partners such as Japan and South
Australia and New Zealand post-natal I
serve in Afghanistan but in view of
declining defense budgets many European
countries the Asia as a region too far
and before divisional labor or division
of tasks to focus on territorial defense
and own backyard such as the Ukraine
crisis in Europe's neighborhood southern
European countries especially fear
destabilizing spell over the middle east
and north africa or menna such as mass
migration and terrorism in Syria in Iraq
with the current ISIS threat as well as
energy and maritime disputes in the
eastern Mediterranean with Turkey Cyprus
and Greece nonetheless I think a
transatlantic division of labor raises
questions of practicality on whether
European secures neighborhood without us
support as we saw in Libya and this also
risks weakening the transatlantic bond
over time so we don't all agree in you
know various chapters in the report
ironically China's rise and global
presence offers a silver lining to
resolve this dilemma because while US
has been pivoting east to Asia as I
mentioned earlier China has been
pivoting west and has joined Club Med by
increasing his economic and maritime
footprint in the Mediterranean so this
presents a rare opportunity I think for
the US and Europe to constructively
engage China on security issues and
together form a common strategy for
regional stabilization and
reconstruction here the transatlantic
community can engage them in what I call
a partnership of necessity meaning
engaging with countries that don't
necessarily share our values but have
sure interest like regional stability
what we work with like-minded allies
will share values and a partnership of
choice to then shape a new monitoring
and security architecture that is still
anchored in a liberal West I think a
partnership of necessity as possible
with China because despite our
differences on issues such as human
rights responsibility to protect or rule
of law the Atlantic community and China
share convergent interest in men on
non-traditional challenges such as
maritime security especially on
counterterrorism and crisis management
now let me outline why and how was China
increasing his presence in meno for
Beijing mana is for
and foremost a region of energy sources
to feed the growing Chinese economy the
under eyes Chinese Communist Party's
legitimacy and survival it is also an
export hub on to Europe and Africa and a
forward front to promote Beijing's one
China policy as well as to combat
terrorism and separatists in China's
Muslim province of Xinjiang the errors
bring her caught China by surprise and
after losing 20 billion dollars in Libya
and evacuating 36,000 Chinese nationals
Beijing is primarily concerned about
deterring another Libya case and
protecting his interests and security of
Chinese citizens abroad so China has
become more proactive in the Levant and
eastern Mediterranean to protect its
interests with three UN Security Council
vetoes in Syria as we saw in 2012
dispatches warships to conduct joint
naval war games with Russia in the east
med back in January this year and then
we saw them also conduct naval war games
with them Iran in the Persian Gulf last
week they've upgraded ties with the US
ally Israel lobby to play a role in the
Middle East peace process and they're
asserting their economic diplomatic and
political footprint to help maintain
regional stability and stability is very
important in Chinese foreign policy they
always talk about way when maintaining
stability so they have a definite stake
in this region China and regional actors
also share similar threats of Islamic
extremism raging fears new Islamist
regimes in the Arab states will be more
supportive a weaker separatists in
Xinjiang and deny Beijing's access to
the energy supply it especially fears
Chinese jihadis in Syria and Iraq
garnering support from international
terror groups and returning to our talk
Chinese territory as well as spawn
homegrown radicalization of China's 20
million Sunni Muslims is a little-known
fact but China's internal state security
internal security budget for the
Ministry of State Security is actually
greater than his defense budget even
dope the Pentagon's obsessed with the
defense budget but as internal security
budget is greater than his defense
budget since the 2009 jinjiang uprising
so Beijing will increasingly exercises
diplomatic and military power to combat
terror and protect its core interest
Beijing is also is increasing its
military presence post Libyan losses by
investing in various Mediterranean Sea
ports I spoke about this earlier that
can accommodate larger cargo ships and
naval vessels concerned about security
of energy supplies china has also sent
troops under un banner to maintain
regional stability so it's not just in
Africa that they have a lot of UN
peacekeeping missions is also
increasingly in the in the Mediterranean
already there are 1000 Chinese troops in
Lebanon and in Cyprus the UN
peacekeeping mission was until August
under the command of a Chinese general
China deployed 500 troops including
combat troops for the first time to the
UN mission in Mali last year to help
stabilize neighboring OPEC member
algeria where they have more than 50,000
workers which is more than they have in
sere in libya and they discussed
possibly offering troops to the west
bank under a UN banner before the recent
hamas an israeli conflict given Western
democracies diminishing capability to
continue being the sole provider of the
global level order in which China has
greatly benefited this is a good
opportunity for China's to step up to
the plate and help share a burden
sharing just last year china overtook us
as the world's largest trading nation
with so with this global economic
interests as a trading stage an
expanding presence in Menna china has an
even bigger stick to ensure maritime
security and freedom of navigation in
the global Commons and we already see
this in there enter policy task force in
the Gulf of Aden they're very interested
in maintaining open seed lines of
communication because some most trade
rrc born eighty to eighty eight percent
or ninety percent ninety-five percent is
Seabourn so they have a stake in
maintaining freedom of navigation and an
open sea lions so how do we operational
this quote this operational Isis
cooperation in Europe's neighborhood
well regional stakeholders in the
eastern Mediterranean such as NATO and
it's Mediterranean Dialogue partners can
engage China in energy and maritime
security and I choose NATO rather than
EU because transatlantic relations
remain institutionalized on security
issues within NATO in the East match
large gas discoveries of Israel and
Cyprus have drawn the attention of
Lebanon Hezbollah Turkey Greece Iran
u.s. EU Russia and China so was a motley
crew of stakeholders there what
potential military conflict over
maritime disputes in the Levantine basin
I came to current territorial disputes
in the East and South China Sea China's
already eyeing to build LNG export
terminal in Cyprus and expressed
interest in joint development of
Israel's Leviathan gas fields so China
has a stake in maintaining energy and
maritime security in the East match now
some skeptics may doubt this idea and
point to China's aggressive behavior in
the western Pacific and unilateral
declarations of air defense
identification zone the ages as well as
we define in customary international law
over the exclusive economic zone and as
true the western Pacific is rife with
long-standing historic rivalries between
China and its neighbors in you know us
asian allies making it very difficult to
engage china for confidence-building
measures in this region but you as an 80
engagement with China in the
Mediterranean we're not feed China
suspicion of encirclement China's always
talking about encirclement in the
western Pacific but in the Med is more
neutral that they don't have any
territorial claims here and it's
geographically far away so i think is a
very fertile area for cooperation
counterterrorism amana is another
cooperative security issue given
al-qaeda in the islamic maghreb the
Akuma is a short threat by NATO's
Mediterranean Dialogue partners as well
as China in 2009 I am actually a Chinese
interests in Algeria after the changing
uprising in a Syria and Iraq China also
faces on we go jihad is linked with al
Qaeda affiliates and Isis the
threatening Jung stability and
territorial integrity and China
estimates there are about 100 Chinese
jihadis in them in Isis NATO and China
can also cooperate in crisis management
in emergency response China has almost 1
million citizens in the Middle Eastern
Africa were piracy and kidnapping are an
increasing problem to conclude China's
increasing interest in men are due to
energy security concerns as well as the
need to protect his overseas citizens
it's given this I think he was an 80
engagement with China in the
Mediterranean is a way to move forward
both for
symantec cohesion as well as regional
stability post air spring and after
using this region as a laboratory for
establishing cooperative mechanisms and
confidence-building measures with China
US and European allies can then take
lessons learned best practices from this
Mediterranean template and then jointly
pivot to Asia to resolve you know to
solve security challenges in the global
Commons and encourage China to resolve
these issues with rural space rather
than power based solutions and perhaps
using this temperature then pivot to
Arctic or else what we're trying to also
have a lot of interest in energy and
maritime security thank you yes hello
good evening everyone um thank you for
coming thank you for hosting us here and
extremely interesting and wide-ranging
discussion I will would like to I won't
take much time but I would like to say a
few words on the topic of this panel
which is about the confrontation and
cooperation in the neighborhood focusing
specifically on the Eastern European
neighborhood I won't go into any detail
on the Ukraine crisis specifically but
I've followed it quite closely so if
this interest we can have that keep that
for the discussion so let me just take
make a few comments about the paradoxes
underlying the patterns of cooperation
and confrontation in the to the east
from the European Union I was greatly
helped by the previous speaker who
outlined pastor of the European model
for the cooperation that evolved over
the past decade or so but there are two
as i mentioned to tensions of paradoxes
here one is that among the new neighbors
of the european union after the big
enlargement of the thousand and four
there's clearly one that is different is
much more important as much more weight
and and a whole different role in the
region than the others and that is
russia and that is very clear if you
look at the
bilateral relations between EU Member
States and Russia but somehow the EU
regional policy conceived in Brussels
was followed a rationale that somehow
Russia didn't really matter or existed
so really there is really a greedy
failure to recognize Russia as a
regional power in in Europe's own
neighborhood and so also lack of
coherence is in treating it as such and
so that is clearly a strategic fela more
specifically in terms of the regional
this neighbourhood policy and what it
offered what we have seen is that
possibly do to sort of a kind of path
dependency possibly due to the existence
of institutional expertise it was
largely modeled on the enlargement
policy even though as the previous
pickax explained quite well there was
never really the membership offer on the
table but that had an enormous political
implication because what the Association
agreements that triggered the crisis the
potential signature of which triggered
the crisis entailed was a far-reaching
cooperation and regulatory approximation
that was similar to the one in
enlargement but so it was offered in
that way without really thinking that
this might not be the only offer on the
table to those partner countries unlike
in the case of enlargement I'm in the
case of lodgement there was no competing
model or no need to reconcile different
parts of cooperation for the partner
states involved and this was not the
case obviously with the Eastern
Partnership project which completely
overlooked the fact that there are very
specific regional interdependencies very
specific regional vulnerabilities
existing patterns of cooperation which
might not probably be the most
beneficial in the long term but they
were not going to go away in the short
and medium term and this is something
that um was not addressed so what
happened just to summarize was that this
very heavily tech
nickel project obviously as as it was
moving along was increasingly
politicized and this politicization was
not added clashed with all these
regional dynamics but there were no
really adequate tools to address this
concerns early on way before the crisis
erupted and as experts in deep point out
some of the concerns about the issues of
trade compatibility these were all
easily resolve able had they been
resolved earlier on but they also means
that we are talking you know nothings
technical in politics we're talking
about again the lack of strategy and
political will to actually see this as a
political question as something to
address is something to push forward to
this sort of new models of cooperation
and reconcile to reconcile different
patterns of cooperation and in the
region and this brings me to the
question of the confrontation in the
neighborhood which is increasingly the
name of the game and we can see probably
a bit less in the US but this is
extremely important in Europe that the
current crisis is increasingly being
discussed in terms of Prussia being the
new the old the emerging security threat
to the new EU member states to the EU as
a whole to the transatlantic community
to the postcode World Order you know you
can get as ambitious as you like in
terms of the how far you want to push
the implications of this new threat but
it's what's important is that we're
really the debate is increasingly moving
towards this new discussion of Russia as
a security threat clearly Russia has
done a lot to to actually promote those
kinds of that kind of debate and those
kinds of discussions with his DS but I
would argue also a lot with its
particular positioning with this
particular rhetoric on the international
arena we have to give credit to the
transatlantic community that tried to
smoothen the terms of the debate
offering off ramps and
um settlements at least in the beginning
before it got really too difficult to to
be trying to seek a compromise but what
I would like to highlight here are the
implications of the fact that the
discussion got so securitized and I
think the first one is that the more we
discuss the modern securitize the
discussion is the more it actually
benefits the status quo in the Eastern
neighborhood and but the status quo and
Easter neighborhood at the moment what
we mean is limited sovereignty
throughout the region frozen conflicts
throughout the region dysfunctional
states throughout the region Ukraine is
clearly a new horrifying example but we
actually have a whole pattern throughout
the region we have Moldova with its
frozen conflict zone we have the
situation in georgia with South Ossetia
we have the escalation of conflict
around nagorno-karabakh between
Azerbaijan Armenia we have a whole range
of tensions and insecurities in Central
Asia that might just as well erupt as we
are speaking and what that means is
basically that as the security stakes go
up for for the region and by implication
also for the neighbors for the European
Union the focus of engagement individual
shifts towards containment the
escalation quick as possible settlements
of really tense situations and
inevitably it moves away from addressing
the structural causes of these problems
and of the crisis itself and so I think
this is something that's being
overlooked really in this discussion is
that although the crisis may have been
triggered by this new geopolitical
rivalry if we look at the domestic
stakeholders in the conflict in Ukraine
in Russia throughout the region if we
look at the kind of really possible ways
of addressing this issue really in the
longer term as opposed to just sort of
making sure there's a ceasefire that
holds all of that is obviously
completely off the table now because of
the securitisation of the whole problem
and that clearly benefits the model of
Russian regional governance and it also
fits with its own model of development I
mean Russia itself is a corrupt and and
in many ways this dysfunctional state
and so you know sort of fits with its
preferred governance pattern and it so
what has happened I would argue is that
the the crisis in Ukraine reframed the
broader policy in the region from one of
cooperation to to the one of throws
threat containment and so what does that
mean really to just to tie quickly the
discussion to the questions of you know
bigger questions of foreign policy
bigger questions of grand strategy if we
liked we would like to call it that way
for the West for the transatlantic
community for the EU more specifically
you know how do we reconcile now this
sudden emerging pressure to to deal with
the to contain a security threat with
what used to be the this sort of the
tenets of the foreign policy which you
know labels labels differ some people
talk about liberal foreign policies that
people talk about ideal is foreign
policy but basically foreign policy
which was much more normatively charged
much more proactive and much more
interventionist even if you like a
foreign policy that were used to be much
more ambitiously aiming at promoting a
certain model of governance and the
structural changes that go with it and
so I think the bigger question that we
really have to be thinking about as we
look at this crisis in the Eastern
neighborhood is really will the new
neighbourhood policy be about the former
or the latter isn't really about
pragmatic threat containment or is it
still about a more more different kind
of engagement and if a different kind of
engagement is still on the table how
then can we pursue it in a credible and
effective manner given the recent
development and I'll stop that
so thank you panelists I'm going to try
and make some comments that draw on both
the report and some of what you've said
while resisting getting into the Ukraine
issue too much leaving that maybe for QA
I should start by saying I'm really
happy to be here because this whole
project combines two questions that I've
been working on for a long time one the
whole question of what is a liberal
order which we struggled with a little
bit in the first session I six years ago
started work on a project that then
became a special issue of the journal
polity called challengers or
stakeholders the bricks in the liberal
world order so we also struggle to
define this and I'll say a word about
that and the other project that I've
worked on for years and years is
European security in Russia and I think
actually Russia's pivot to a brick
strategy has been connected to the
failure of its ability to find a
relationship with the West that it found
satisfactory let me start by saying
something about order as a kind of
realist international relations my view
of order is norms and values go together
with power and so we can speak of a
euro-atlantic order underpinned by us
power and to a large extent european
economic power but the whole idea of a
liberal order in a global sense was of
course came into being as a question
after the end of the cold water war when
the aspiration was to try and integrate
the former Soviet countries and
additionally following that a rising
China into a Western conception of a
rule-based order and in my sense this is
in my view this is not something we've
actually achieved
I don't think it's possible to achieve
to integrate non rule-based basically
illiberal states whether they're rising
powers re emerging powers or Russia is
both rising and declining throughout
this whole history is a separate
question but it's an aspiration and it's
a good aspiration but we need to be
pragmatic about it and the Russia case
and where we are today I think is
reflective of the problem of doing this
initially if we look back to what
happened on the Russia side leaving the
China side for a minute apart the Russia
case Russia was so weak after the Soviet
collapse that it was not too difficult
for the West to move into integrating
Central European countries the european
union european states in western europe
of course were not so eager to do this
they were more engaged in a deepening
exercise and not so interested in
widening europe and that's why NATO came
before the EU but nonetheless it was a
good argument to stabilize Central
Europe and prevent a vacuum power Russia
wasn't thrilled with this idea but it
didn't have the power to prevent it and
as a kind of side payment to Russia we
tried to encourage Russia to democratize
we tried to we the United States in
particular but also the European Union
tried to partner with Russia and I wrote
a whole my monograph on this and argued
that these these special relationships
or partial integration strategies can
only work when Russia was weak and when
it recovered its power it was going to
be more assertive and questioned whether
this kind of order could work and that's
in fact what we've seen Russia deeply
resented I don't think it feared so much
as a security element NATO's enlargement
or EU enlargement until it got to
Ukraine and Georgia and countries
particularly on the from the former
Soviet Union
but it resented the fact that it was
excluded and did not seem to understand
that Russia could not be integrated into
this order that was value-based whether
Russia EU partnership or Russian Ino
partnership on its terms and those terms
were not rule base but in fact a lack of
conditionality Russia's idea of order is
rather more like a concert of Europe
where great powers have spheres of
influence and are the major power
players and rule makers in the world and
smaller states like Poland Czech
Republic Hungary and so on are basically
part of great power spheres and they
adjusted to the fact that you existed
but they were never happy about the fact
that they were excluded and eventually
we saw this reflected in mid Vedas plan
for a new security arrangement in Europe
both in the context of Russia and NATO
and Russia youth Russia began to realize
it had no bargaining power with the EU
or NATO it could only hope to bargain
for a new agreement and of course
neither NATO nor the EU was interested
in an overarching structure where Russia
would play in equal role so this is
where we're at and then the problematic
way of dealing with Ukraine has led to a
situation where Russia has now where
we've seen a power shift and despite its
current economic problems we have to
remember before 2008 Russia had gone
through a period where its power had
recovered and we had a Russian economy
about the size of Germany in fact all of
the BRIC countries Brazil Russia India
and China leaving aside South Africa are
now in the top ten world economies and
they are interested in having the power
and influence that goes with this so on
the Russia side this is not a difficult
explanation and Europe and the
transatlantic community is still left
with the challenge I've argued that is
the challenge that confronted us at the
end of the Cold War how do we deal with
an assertive illiberal country
that is not that wants to play a role
and yes we do have shared interests in
some respects but not on our terms and
this is the same challenge it's just now
with the stronger Russia with a
modernized I don't want to overstate his
modernize military power but at least
the tip of it on the China side let me
just say a couple words before I turn it
over to Jack here the whole notion of
integrating China's responsible
stakeholder has been in the forefront
because China is the rising power Russia
is the failed Challenger and it's still
a problem in the European context and we
shouldn't underestimate it but it's not
the Challenger that china is to their
credit it was the russian it was
actually putin himself and the foreign
ministry that that had their own pivot
to create this bricks idea and most of
my colleagues gave me a lot of flack for
even thinking this was a project worth
working on but here we are now six years
later and the BRICS countries that have
literally nothing in common on
completely different continents through
kind of acted jujitsu and a very clever
I would argue Russian diplomatic
strategy have come together and started
to form parallel institutions to the
existing governance structures in the
world and this is a really remarkable
development and I think Russia was in
part motivated as I said because it
wasn't getting any traction on its
us-russian or european russian side so
on that sense these BRICS countries
actually have a lot in common they have
a deep resentment and I include in the
democratic countries India and Brazil
not just the resurgent a powerful
growing powerful China which is of
course the dominant player now and
Russia with all of its problems they
have a deep resentment against the fact
that the sort of legacy powers not the
United States which is still the
dominant power but the legacy powers in
Europe are trying to encourage the
emulation of norms but still sitting on
their
physicians and don't want to give them
up in my last my most recent publication
on this I detailed in excruciating
detail which I won't go into with you on
the IMF negotiations over shares and
this is emblematic of the problem
Europeans will redefine what it means to
have a share in the IMF so they can
protect their positions and it's quite
disarming to sit in the Russian Foreign
Ministry or in Chinese ministries and
have officials know this excruciating
detail and complain about how they won't
budge and so if they won't budge these
countries these rising or emerging
powers and merging economies want to
find their own voice and their own
contributions and of course they want I
would argue an all stop with this not
just the formal power that in some cases
they've been denied of course Russia and
China both have seats on the UN Security
Council India and Brazil desperately
want that same power but in the Bretton
Woods governance structure they want to
be the rule makers while still free
riding on the existing institutions they
want to be having the formal power and I
think even more important the informal
power where the informal power you make
decisions you set the agenda basant
behind the scenes and you also get to
break the rules nothing aggravates these
countries more than the fact that that
the u.s. especially and to some extent
the Europeans are hypocritical that of
course we engage in hypocrisy we
bypassed the UN when it suits us to be
used for us without in its imprimatur
yet we get upset when Russia is fighting
a proxy war in in in in in Ukraine or
when China is it's asserting its power
in the South China Sea so this informal
power which gives you the right to pass
make the rules for others and sometimes
be exempt from them is only possible if
you have outside options China has them
and now we see some of these countries
in informal partnerships I don't want to
over
state how important the bricks and these
other institutions are they're not but
when it suits their interests they will
coalesce with China to get to get their
way and our interests Americans and
Europeans the transatlantic community is
to find a better path forward to deal
with these challenges because I think
we've really failed so far thank you so
I'm so much on the same page with
Cynthia that I can be very quick let me
start by talking about Michaels point
that the eu-ukraine agreement was fully
compatible with ukraine's CIS membership
and when you say that as a legal matter
i'm sure that that must be true and that
the negotiators thought about that but
as a functional matter my question is
can a transparent rule of law market
system be compatible with corruption
oligarchy patronage and rent-seeking you
know we have the folk sayings that the
bad money drives out the good or the
rotten apple spoils the whole barrel you
know I don't know whether the answer to
this question is obvious it probably
requires a lot of thought and analysis
but I don't see how these things are
easily compatible this matters because
not only is that the old plan but it's
also evidently the new plan for Ukraine
to have a barrel with
the apples in it rotten and somehow hope
that the rest of the apples are going to
stay so juicy and succulent that the the
people that are stuck with a rotten
apples are going to say oh I wish we
were in the part of Ukraine that had the
good fruit this is I think related to
the the largest issue and the one that
Cynthia focused on raised by this whole
report the introductory essay and the
concluding essay to the report talked
about talked about the idea of moving
from the current liberal rules-based
order to quote a new rules-based order
that would somehow accommodate
non-western illiberal powers ideas about
rules into the system and to me this
sounds like a barrel that has a lot of
rotten apples in with the good ones and
and I think that this probably
misconstrues the the direction in which
the international system is heading
instead of moving from liberal rules to
new robust rules that are somehow not
really liberal I think we're moving more
towards an international system that's
going to be based not so much on rules
but is going to be ray based much more
on bargaining anchored in power and the
self-interest of actors rather than
rules now Christina's presentation
pointed out that sometimes the interests
of say the Chinese in the Mediterranean
can coincide with the interests of the
Europeans and based on pure
self-interest you can come up with a
bargain where
but will cooperate and provide a
collective good but that's not because
they're following rules that's just a
happenstance of convergence of interests
now liberal rules have that they hang
together and have like a rationale
behind them it's what Adam Smith said
that liberal rules are a system that you
know when they're working properly at
any rate they align private interest
with public interest the idea of the
invisible hand illiberal social systems
you know they may have rules but if they
have rules they're very different kind
there the rules of client ilysm and
there the the rules or maybe a better
word is just strategies of mercantilism
and so illiberal states like China and
Russia I see as parasitic on the liberal
world where there as Cynthia said free
riding on liberalism's rules and the
bargaining that is increasingly going on
is over how much leeway to give the
illiberal powers to free ride or cheat
on the rules of the system and Cynthia
says it's not that the US doesn't cheat
on its own rules but when the u.s.
cheats on its own rules it's at least
some of the time with the purpose of
trying to stabilize its system by by
going outside the rules and and I think
that's an important distinction just
briefly on Katerina that who used the
term securitization of discourse and I
thought your analysis was was good but I
that terms
me as a euphemism for coercion by Russia
and I would rather not use that kind of
euphemism because so it leads this
circles back to you know what my first
point so poroshenko's a prescription for
his country is well we're not going to
really be able to stop coercion naked
coercion exercise of brutal power by
Russia and but we're going to win in the
long run because we're going to have a
better more attractive social system and
well I don't think so because I think
Russia is going to use its coercive
power to make sure that Ukraine stays a
really unattractive social system with
an economy that's dysfunctional and so
if we're talking about that or if we're
talking about NATO's response to the
Russian threat in the bulk Baltic we're
either going to have to we can't just
change the discourse to long run you
know non-security thinking we're going
to either have to exercise counter power
either military or a serious economic
embargo not just the kind of four sho
sanctions that we've had so forth or
otherwise we're going to have to resign
resign ourselves to losing in the short
run losing Ukraine possibly even using
losing the Baltics have you looked at a
map and just wait them out until you
know Russia once again collapses from
its own shortcomings thanks
very interesting open questions that
just maybe a bullet one I think it's
realistic or something but the
accountability and legitimacy then we're
talking about different states and how
they behave into a water right and
healthy horse western and we talked
about some states objection no
accountability and we never actually and
we reward with other states we didn't
mention about legitimacy of actually
being in war you know us does not talk
to us about how the release in a
question to you is all me I'm just why
don't we also talked about you know
what's driving the world water into the
world Germany why this journey this
leads euro it has to be probably with
domestic politics people right but we
don't talk about Russia White's Russia's
shape with some kind of political
interests where does this come from and
why isn't is important in our
understanding of the post-crescent world
we start with one of you respond what I
just wanted to maybe go directly to a
more specific question on on Ukraine
Russia um I don't think we disagree in
our analysis so what's going on in your
brain I mean there's there's no way you
could you're going to have a wall along
the the current ceasefire online and
then a new economic miracle and you know
southern unprecedented wave of
democratization within the rest of
Ukraine that's gonna make Dom springy
and emigrate and then what I mean the
others jump the wall like this before we
were back in nineteen eighty nine and
this is exactly my worry when I talk
about the fact that the structural
forces which are really about this take
the squab dysfunction and functionality
corruption that sets in Russia Russia's
that's exactly what Russia's are playing
to do I mean they don't have to they
basically Ukraine didn't have to bake
physically vortex if as long as this
sort of climate innovis ability to have
an impact on domestic politics in ways
that that is an ability in a way that is
creating instability way that is
blocking the reforms that that's good
enough and then there's a whole regional
parking ah damn so really I mean what
poroshenko says we're going to win in
the long run I mean that's an election
campaign mode only that what he has to
say about it there's not many and
there's not really any serious basis for
believing that
the near future so what I am just to
sort of say the securitisation term I
bet the question is really another
tuition the one is the question of how
do we respond to the immediate crisis
that erupted the other one is the
question of strategy what I was
basically trying to argue is that we
have to be thinking about clothes you
know we obviously have to respond to
very complete military threat and they
know very concrete situation on the
ground also to the fact that Crimea was
annexed in a very peaceful way but still
this is an unprecedented violation of
international law right and somehow it's
almost embarrassing that the
international community especially and
the European community reacted much more
in a much more passionate and an out way
with much more outrage to to the
accident that happened with the with the
malayan like it was a terrible tragedy
could still one would are you an
accident and was so silent when one
actually you know whole piece of their
very good annex in such a button play
right so I think the quote so there's a
question of response and we shouldn't be
really sort of trying to to be nice to
Russia just for the sake of being nice
to Russia but there's a question of
strategy what I'm saying is that if we
only get stuck with this or very stupid
ice thinking that over your back you
know and I was referring really to the
sort of dominant debate especially in
Europe we are back to the Cold War it's
all about containment it's all about
nuclear
who has them who doesn't there were not
i think we are under vacuum a more
strategic vision of what European
foreign policy should look like what its
regional policy should look like and so
I think these two things have to be
brought together on the table for us to
have a more fruitful and productive
discussion yeah I mean I appreciate very
much all of the comments certainly from
jacket and Cynthia and but I wonder
whether the division of the world into
countries which are liberal on the one
side and a liberal on the other you know
is the end of the story you know their
countries where we know that rotten
apples constitute half of the country
and these countries are basically
irredeemable and therefore who are we
trying to kid in believing that we can
in some way extend aspects of a more
liberal order for example through an EU
trade and agreement to these countries I
mean you know when we look back over the
last 20 30 40 50 years certainly after
the Second World War and shortly well
and even in the 50s the number of West
European countries that were given up as
hopeless cases I mean Italy was widely
regarded as a completely hopeless case
because of corruption and bureaucracy
and incompetents now those problems
haven't disappeared entirely but you
know it is one of the eighth richest
countries in the world and it is
functional and there are aspects of rule
of law that functioned there romania was
regarded as a completely hopeless case
there are still you know problems of
corruption rather petty on the whole
it's not the Soviet model it's not the
Bulgarian model we've seen backsliding
in Hungary in Bulgaria to some degree in
Croatia even but they seem to be on a
certain path and I just wondered whether
we have to give up on Ukraine entirely
on the grounds that it's clearly
illiberal the corruption has reached
such a degree that the rotten apples are
such that we can't really try and engage
you know those generations or others
there who would like to see a different
evolution the same question to certain
degree exist even around the
Mediterranean and in North
Africa we had an interesting meeting
with Ganesha from another party in
Tunisia the other day in Washington and
it's just conceivable that Tunisia
despite all the odds and all the
refugees and all the smuggling across
the border with Libya and so on you know
is not necessarily in this
winner-take-all kind of mode and might
be open to some moves in this direction
so you know the the view that who are we
trying to kid you know really don't try
and engage with these countries they're
part of another system another view of
the world they're always going to react
in this way I think even China you know
and Russia I mean WTO has imposed
certain constraints on China and so on
so I just rather wonder whether this
sort of Manichean view not fully
Manichean but I mean you're a bad apple
countries and not it really is the last
word on that possible evolution Oh
actually can I respond ourself yes um
yeah I just want to say on you know the
worth of us in Europe NATO engage in
China on interspace issues in miniature
ainia we can leverage those interest yes
they coincide but then we can use that
as our confidence building measures a
template to then Forge a new consensus
on global security norms during the Cold
War you was in the USSR you've got
liberal bloggers you've got a liberal
bloc well we had agreements like
incidents at sea so that was maritime
security so we agreed it was messing 72
agreement and we agreed you know on
certain issues to prevent escalation
accidents like not dropping hazardous
materials you know near ships or you
perform acrobatics over ships and what
happened so we actually achieved a
Norman a consensus even with a liberal
bloc at that time so that's what I'm
seeing that we can leverage this and
then bill sort of new rules of
engagement or some of the sort of motors
avanti and in the Gulf of Aden that's
sort of a micro example what we can
achieve in gulf of aden you have you
know NATO it's very hard about you've
got NATO you've got you now for you've
got us lock on by maritime force then
you have you know Russian and India and
China and these other enjoy
vessels there but we have this some
cooperative mechanism called shade you
know I shared awareness deconfliction so
that we can coordinate and have some
some cooperative measures so that we
don't bump into each other have
accidents so that's sort of a basic
template and confidence-building measure
to fill these you know through new rules
of engagement and normanok insensitive
especially in the global comments for
global security door I wanted to say
that newborn are you there's no question
that you can have a cooperative
interests come out of these cooperative
security from incidents and see which is
a good example to work any other piracy
as well which is another one you
mentioned a whole series of them the
problem and I think we saw this in the
long history of Russia NATO cooperation
is the expected outcome of habits of
cooperation then resolving the big
security issues it doesn't work and I
don't think it will work any better in
the US or European or western China
relations than it did in Russia needle
and for the basic reason that we have
these fundamental differences and the
cooperation at one level doesn't
necessarily extend to the higher level
where political differences or sources
so I'm not sure that's been demonstrated
from any of those cases that you go from
one set of cooperative mechanisms and
the new relationship with Russia it's
the same problem or with Ukraine you
know everything but institutions this is
just naive the whole Eastern Partnership
was naive
think that that Russia when it became
powerful wasn't going to gym objec and
some of this could been avoided Russia
is actually more economically reform the
less corrupt than Ukraine and yet now
everything has been said that I don't
want to overstate that but it has worked
harder at modernization thank you indie
stuff in this evening I mean from the
two randoms so I find sumthin wrestle or
mystical that Hebrew world order some
others something optimistic here I tried
to and he observed a Brahmin even faster
let's put the side libra world order a
wire that is to say so today with these
two handles we are discussing father
even with all the accurate background
late to change of the world and now they
are not gonna tell exchange of the world
or so my question is so after the
setting of the war and possible we can
also up their host code or walk so the
Negro ball order becomes changing world
all you gotta share the ball so the
implication is that we want to establish
a new hood order and listen you order
that I'm from China rehab so no chance
perspective okay sure I will not use
this term bugler wat water I will just
say that you would own the polychaetes
so their new one order our show who we
are joined to establish new donor water
contents will be the new leaf new model
what happen how to create such a key
steps in such a new world order whether
well I are you like or not we just
wanted a new world order okay this is
very important is very fundamental to
the world of the peace the video about
them and initially gaga so I think
whether you are from the words are often
atleast a reading from stars on was
moonshine America and Europe actually we
just have been here we have shared
income common area that is a rebound
stepping on your daughter this new order
based on words what kind of laws that
process nada just now okay person this
or that or can even though you put
together
well battle so here I can I think at
least tell me that target of you are
Buddhist God's discuss about maybe I
didn't you code but my understanding my
prospect oh my installation on a leash
copies so we just wanted you would think
what we should use someone's respond to
that and with that we're going to get to
wrap this up because for time okay so i
think we'll start with our panelists big
question well i think it's a tremendous
question to wrap up our discussion I'm
afraid I can only answer it in the
negative i think the New World Order
contrary to our expectations until
recently will not be achieved by just
the progressive extension of the Western
model being adopted by one group of
countries after another which was the
way we tended to proceed until now and I
think this new world order there is to
be one will be one where different
conceptions of the internal order of
states and how they rate relate to each
other have to co-exist but I can see
what it won't be but I don't really see
yet very clearly what it will be I don't
have much to add up to that actually I
mean I think it's increasing theorists
you know devolution increasing
regionalism and I think you know there's
like you know we're trying to beef up
our the own Western liberal order we
know with T tip and and and in our
allies or a democracy is no teeth with
TPP and to get our own house in order so
we can project out again and of course
you know China is a rising challenger
China and Russia they are you know
weaving their own blogs with a Eurasian
Union of the Shanghai Cooperation
Organization there's overlapping with
Briggs that there are non-western so you
know we have these emergent blocks but I
think because we should still coordinate
and have some sort of you know motors
Von D not necessarily operandi but
volunteer just you know peacefully
coexisting and that's why focused on the
global comments because it affects
everybody and so that's where we can you
know achieve a lot of maybe some
consensus
at least global security norms because
these are emerging these are new
emerging non-traditional security
challenges we don't quite have a Norman
Norman of consensus on that yet because
it's new so this is a good opportunity
for us to at least cooperate and reach
some sort of consensus on these rising
issues and new norms are they starting
from this point well just very briefly
we have talked a bit about the question
of you know what's liberal the liberal
between the world order I think also
they basically summarizing what the
others have said also the bit about the
order may be sending instead of as
somewhat to stop the invasion of
international politics in the context
which as we as we recognize this
increasingly dynamic is increasingly
multi-color and is also facing so many
new sets which by definition should
provoke innovation and and new forms of
interaction as opposed to sort of just
trying to see whether the existing you
know how to fit it with the existing
rules so I think yeah you know I would
imagine that you know it useful to start
with a question you know what happened
to the liberal World Order but that's
clearly not going to be the kind of
framework that's going to describe
what's coming
out of it after that I agree with a lot
of said I'll just add that I see order
and governance as intimately connected
with power and where there's a gap
between the power holders rising powers
and our aspirations of governance it's
not going to work so that requires those
whose power is waning and I think this
is mostly Europe less of us need to
either rejuvenate their power and I wish
Europe especially would do this it would
be a better partner for the United
States it free rides as much as rising
powers do my view and then we would have
a better ability to to find solutions to
ax come where to accommodate and where
to resist our differences with powers
that don't share so I'm an optimist
about the liberal domestic and
international word I think that
liberalism is a system that has solved
problems of authority and participation
far better than any
their type of governance system that the
world has seen its you know not the end
state of the universe but you know
compared to what else what else is in
town it's you know still the best
product product out there illiberal
states have historically been very
successful at bursts of catch up
industrialization or economic
development but then after the easy
growth phase that comes from bringing
underutilized factors of production
especially labor into a kind of copycat
version of the superficial aspects of
liberal modernity they run out of gas
because they haven't solved the problem
of authority and participation as well
as liberalism
does and they come crashing down or
alternatively there like China and
Russia hey their economic success is
largely parasitical on the consumer
economies that have been created by
liberal capitalism and that can only go
so far until they come up with their own
Mazel and if you know it sometimes they
then become liberal and solve their
problem and other times they don't
become liberal and come crashing down
and I think that's what's going to
happen again yeah trying to catch it
thank you enormously for the spring
before we're going to have a big
conference on the Congress of Vienna so
do you know what should we say the
European global governance these
questions
for